car chases make up some of the most
thrilling scenes in movie history we've
seen them in some form or another since
the early days of moviemaking
[Music]
[Applause]
we talked to Wade Eastwood a stunt
coordinator who most recently worked on
Mission Impossible fall out one of the
movies best scenes was a car chase
through Paris we asked him how do you
train to be in a car chase
how do you plan one and when the day
comes how do you actually shoot it
here's a little peek into how an epic
car chase is brought to life
[Music]
[Music]
before a shoot stunt drivers will drive
around in a variety of different
vehicles to get the feel of how each of
them drives training most often focuses
on improving drift and precision skills
actors and stunt drivers will drive
around surrounded by cones to keep them
unmarked being a stunt coordinator
doesn't just mean planning action scenes
productions sometimes pour millions of
dollars into a given car chase so it's
necessary that it is done as safely as
possible before I start testing I have
to look at what we want to do and see
how much risk I can eliminate and then
during the testing phase I we evaluate
my risk assessment and when I get to a
place that my my risk assessment is is
not a high risk assessment it's a medium
to low risk then it's a doable stunt
they have to assess the surface they're
going to be shooting on terrain who
plays an important role when building a
project the public streets in Paris on
the sea slippery surfaces a couple of
stones can move you've got you know then
you keep transitioning from couples to
tarmac asphalt so you've got different
grip levels and you might be on a
mountain road that's dusty because the
winds are blown when I'm doing a
sequence I'll always try and sweep the
roads and clean them so there's
consistency the surface once the casting
crew is thoroughly prepared it's time to
film the chase
to capture the most dynamic chase scene
it's important to shoot it from every
possible angle it's not unusual to see a
car covered in cameras camera mounts are
attached to a car as well as lights the
cars in Fallout were free driven in some
instances though the car being filmed
will be towed this is usually done when
there's a lot of dialogue and a need for
the driver to concentrate on their
performance it's also best to do this if
the performers vision is too obscured by
all the cameras mounted to the hood of
the car to get every angle imaginable a
crew will use a Russian armed camera
tracking system in addition eastwood
swears by a tracking motorcycle that he
uses he mounts a stabilized camera to a
bike which can go from one inch off the
ground to seven feet off the ground in
just two seconds a lot of the car chases
you see are done practically sure visual
effects have to be used for certain
details but it's rare you'll find a car
chase done completely in front of a
green screen you'll really only see that
for certain stunts that are too
dangerous to do in real life
[Music]
even when a car chases shop practically
there will always be an element of
visual trickery involved making fifty
miles an hour
looked like a hundred miles and I look
exciting which is the trick that we have
to do in film because for everyone to
keep up with you at a hundred miles an
hour cameras and things happen far too
quickly and accidents would happen to
even break up so we have to tone things
down but make the car look excited but
making a good car chase is about more
than just producing thrills driving fast
and conquering the most impossible of
terrains that's not always the big
spectacle for me with a car chase it it
has to be story if I'm invested in the
character in the car then what happens
with the cars in the tale to me but it's
more about going on the journey with
that character in the car it's why Tom
Cruise Vin Diesel and audiences
everywhere will never be able to get
enough of a good car chase
you